what's going on everybody and welcome to
part two of the neural networks from
scratch videos in this video what we're
gonna do is just continue building upon
what we've got so far the first order of
business however I am going to change
all these values and moving forward I'm
gonna keep doing this to be exactly the
same values that we use in the book that
way if anybody is following along there
you can the videos are gonna match the
book exactly so the first thing that
we're gonna do is we're gonna change
these inputs these are going to be 1 2 &
3 and then the weights and again these
are just totally made-up values for now
later
the neural network will will randomly
initialize weights and then what's going
to be tweaking those weights is really
like back propagation so for now though
we're just just making them up but I
just want to use the same made-up values
as from the book so 0.2 0.8 and negative
0.5 and the bias used was 2 so running
this we get 2.3 that's what we wanted so
okay so now that we've got that I got a
couple of questions about you know why
is there why is there only one bias and
then some people were asking about
weight so I've just kind of re-explained
weights but why only one bias so if
that's kind of confusing to you let's
take a peek see at what we what we've
coded so far so imagine you've got this
full neural network okay it's fully
connected all that and then what we've
done is we've selected a single neuron
from that network and in this case that
neuron had three inputs to it now
looking at this you can already see okay
we've got three connections but only one
neuron so in terms of bias there's only
going to be one bias associated with
this neuron but because we've got three
inputs that means we have three weights
so every input has its own unique weight
hmm but every neuron just has its one
bias you don't have a bias per weight so
from here what's happening is yes we've
got the exact same inputs that I've
coded here the weights that we've got
here the bias that we've got here and
then basically all this just gets added
into this this massive formula here of
inputs times the weights plus the by
to give us our final output of 2.3 so
now what I'd like to do is let's add one
more input in this case so before we do
that though I want to kind of solidify
what exactly are these inputs so these
inputs in theory could be one of two
things it could either be truly input as
in like values from the input layer of a
neural network which is just going to be
a vector of values so in theory this
could be an example of an input layer
now in the example that we showed
visually that is exactly what it was
right we had this fully connected neural
network and then we kind of singled out
that one neuron that was in that first
hidden layer and in that case it was
pulling values from like the first true
layer which would be our input layer of
the neural network so what is that input
layer the input layer is simply whatever
values you have that you're tracking so
let's let's say you've got an example
that you're trying to predict failure or
not failure for servers or computer
equipment right and so you've got
various sensors like heat sensors and
humidity sensors and stuff like that
right so each value here in these inputs
if this is your input layer each unique
value here could be a value from a
separate sensor now later when we add
four inputs we're going to kind of
simulate it's coming from somewhere in
the middle of the neural network so your
inputs to a neuron could either be from
the true input layer that are values
from something like say a sensor or a
group of sensors in this case or they
could be outputs from neurons themselves
so I'll show an example of that when we
get there but for now let's say we add
one more input so rat so one two three
and then a two point five so now we've
gotten there so again we have the same
fully connected neural network but this
time what we're going to do is we're
gonna select a different neuron so as
you can see actually this time we're
going to model one of the output layer
neurons in this case though if the
calculation is
to remain totally the same now in the
future when we start calculating the
activation functions you'll see that the
output layer will have a different one
but for now the calculation of inputs
times the weights plus the bias that
actually stays the same so the other
thing that's different here is this
neuron is taking inputs from not maybe
sensors or whatever it's actually taking
inputs from one of the hidden layers but
it turns out it outputs the same stuff
right so in this case for this neuron
with four unique inputs what's going to
change well you're just going to have
one extra unique weight but do you have
any extra biases no we're still only
modeling a single neuron it doesn't
matter that four neurons were the input
to this neuron because the outputs of
those four neurons become the input of
the new neuron and once that neuron is
already generated its output it's
already if it was like a hidden layer
neuron it's already taken to account the
bias so in this case again when we're
modeling for inputs to a single neuron
we're only going to have a single bias
so let's go ahead and code that so
really all that changes here is yes
we've got the two point five the weights
actually we need one more unique weight
and in this case we used 1.0 1.0 and
then the the only change here is quite
simple right we're just going to copy
paste and then I'm going to just modify
this three and then come over here three
and then just scrolling out I think it's
pretty easy to follow it at this point
very simple as part one Harrison would
say and yeah cool so let's go ahead and
run that and we get four point eight
very simple so now what happens if
instead of modeling so in this case
where we were modeling only one neuron
but with four inputs and then before
that one neuron with three inputs what
if we want to model three neurons with
four inputs so in the case of three
neurons with four inputs what we're
looking at is going to be something like
this
now in this case what we're doing is
we're showing basically the output layer
as you'll see later on the output layer
will have some differences but the first
part of doing the inputs times the
weights plus the bias is going to indeed
be identical
all right so code wise what we're going
to need here is if it's for inputs into
three neurons this means the inputs are
gonna stay the same we already have four
inputs defined but what we're going to
need or since there's three neurons that
means there's going to be three unique
weight sets and each weight set is going
to have four values because there's four
inputs and then four biases we're also
going to need three unique or separate
biases so let's go ahead and code that
in I am going to just copy paste paste
we're going to call these weights one
two and three and then for bias we're
gonna copy paste paste and we're going
to have bias one two three now for the
people who are like absolutely crying
right now we will eventually convert
this to a loop and then eventually we
won't even be using raw Python anymore
we're going to use numpy to kind of go
through this and make this way better
but for now we're keeping it very simple
just so nothing is lost on anybody
hopefully so what we've got here are
weights 1 2 3 and what I'm gonna do is I
am going to again use the exact same
values from the book so zero point five
negative zero point nine one zero point
two six negative zero point five and
then for weights three it is negative
zero point two six negative zero point
two seven zero point 17 is zero point
zero point eight seven and that is
actually not a negative cool for bias
one is still a two bias to will be a
three bias three will be zero point five
hopefully I got that right okay so
that's changed now what is going to
change here on the output so when we're
just modeling a single neuron the output
is going to be a single value
this case though we're actually modeling
three neurons so we're modeling a layer
so to speak so the layer output is going
to look an awful lot like the input so
in this case the input again it could
have been maybe the input layer but it
could also be input from other neural
like an another layer in the neural
network so it's good the output for this
should look an awful lot like this only
rather than having four values it should
have three so let's make that change so
what we're gonna do is basically convert
this this will now be a list and I'm
gonna say comma here and I think we
should be able to get away with copy and
what we'll do is come down here tab tab
paste paste now inputs will always be 0
1 2 3 okay but waits now what we're
going to need to do is change this to 1
2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 and then again here 1 2
3 and then bias needs to also be 1 2
whoops 2 3
and don't forget your comma here and
yeah I think that's relatively
acceptable let's go ahead and run that
and what we see here for the output for
this these three neurons it's four point
eight one point two one and two point
three eight five so again looking at
everything you've got your fully
connected neural network we've selected
three neurons with four inputs each
those four inputs for every neuron will
remain the same but what's different is
each neuron is gonna have a unique set
of weights for each unique input and
each neuron will have its own unique or
separate bias so when modeling for the
first neuron you've got your your weight
set one your second neuron is going to
have your weight set to and it's also
going to have its own bias and when
modeling for neuron three again its own
unique weight set its own unique bias
and it will also have its own unique
outputs and with all of the other 'nor
and the calculation for that output is
just simply going to be those inputs
times those weights plus the bias so
because we've got three neurons it's
gonna be three unique outputs and each
of those again the calculation is pretty
simple it's just inputs times the
weights plus the bias for every single
neuron okay that's all the code for now
if you have any problem understanding
anything up to this point please ask
your questions below if you're a little
confused about like what weights are
this should start to become a little
more obvious so imagine you want to
start changing these these output values
here how would you do it well you have
two options right you could start tanked
because the inputs you can't really
change the inputs because the inputs are
outputs from like either a previous
layer or they're like your actual data
from you know your actual input data
from features like sensor data or
something like that so you really can
never change the inputs directly but you
actually can by changing weights and
biases so you can change because the
inputs what are those those are outputs
often from other neurons so how do we
tweak those well we do that by tweaking
the weights and the bias right so that
is the that is the struggle hood of deep
learning his figure out how best to tune
those weights and those biases but
that's how we can start to have an
impact on these output values and when
we get to it that is the whole you know
crux of deep learning is the kind of
back propagation calculating gradient
and like figuring out how do we adjust
weights and biases to get the output
values that we want for like the vast
array of inputs that we might have so
anyway if you are confused about weights
and biases hopefully now it's starting
to at least become clear that okay to
change to actually make an impact on
this these these outputs the way that we
would do that is by tweaking these
weights and these biases now how we do
that
that is a mystery that we will be
solving much later in the series but for
now I my hope is that all of this is
very clear Python code we will be
cleaning this up we're going to
convert this well first I'll just show
like obviously we loop through this we
can make this into array data first and
then but also when we do that we're
gonna have to talk about arrays versus
tensors which is a surprisingly heated
topic sometimes matrices all that so we
have to cover a little bit more about
that and then also some other operations
that we're going to be performing so
anyway that's all for now questions
comments concerns feel free to leave
them below if you're interested in the
book you can get it at NFS i/o
eventually the draft will be complete
but the the book is even right now even
though it's in draft form is basically
everything from starting to code your
neurons the all the activation functions
to actually training back propagation
actually getting the neural network to
go through a training loop and actually
learn things even we've just released
the regularization section as well so if
you're watching this on release that's
kind of where we are right now
pretty far pretty far along certainly
much further along than this so if
you're looking to get a jump on the
material that's how you can do it again
NFS dot IO otherwise I will see you guys
in the next video